Let's continue with our
orange juice producing example
In this situation I want to think about
what a rational quantity of orange juice might be
what would be a rational quantity
of orange juice to produce
given a market price
So let's say that
the market price right now is
50 cents a gallon
and I'm going to assume that
there are many producers here
so we're going to have to be price takers
and obviously we want to charge
as much as we can per gallon
but if we charge even a penny
over 50 cents a gallon
then people are going to buy
all of their orange juice
from other people
so this is the price that we can charge
50 cents per gallon
So, if we think about it
in terms of marginal revenue
per incremental gallon
well that first incremental gallon
we're going to get 50 cents
the next incremental gallon
we're going to get 50 cents for that one
and the next one
we're going to get 50 cents as well.
for the first thousand gallons
we're going to get 50 cents
for each of those gallons
for the first 10 thousand gallons
we'll get 50 cents per gallon
So, our marginal revenue curve
will look something like this
Our marginal revenue is a flat curve
right at 50 cents a gallon
so that is our marginal revenue
at 50 cents
at a market price of 50 cents per gallon
now in this situation
what's a reasonable quantity
that we would want to produce?
Now there's two dynamics here
we want to produce as much as possible
so that we can spread our fixed cost
over those gallons
that's one way of thinking about it
or, another way of thinking about it is
we have a certain amount of fixed cost
we are spending $1000 no matter what
so why don't we try to get
as much revenue as possible
to try to make up for those fixed costs
or if we think about it
in terms of average fixed cost
the more quantity that we produce
the component of the cost for that
from the fixed cost
goes down and down and down
so we want to have as much as possible
to spread our fixed costs
now the one thing that we do need to think about is
especially once we kind of get beyond the little dip
in the marginal cost curve
and as we produce more and more units
the marginal cost is going up higher and higher and higher
we don't want to produce so much
that the cost of producing that incremental unit
the marginal cost of that incremental unit
is more than the marginal cost of that actual
or the marginal cost of that incremental unit
is not higher than the marginal revenue
that we're getting on that incremental unit
so, until marginal revenue is equal to marginal cost
or another way to think about it
you don't want marginal cost
and this is after we go to this little dip here
we're trying to do as much as possible
marginal cost is going higher and higher and higher
we don't want to produce this much right over here
because here the cost for that extra gallon is higher
than what we're going to get for that extra gallon
looks like that cost for that extra gallon
might be 53 cents
while we're only gonna get 50 cents
for that extra gallon
so every extra gallon we produce over here
we're going to be losing money
so you don't want marginal cost
to be greater than marginal revenue
so when you look at the curves like this
and make sense to just say
when does marginal revenue equal marginal cost?
and that's this point right over here
and that is the rational amount to produce
so that is 9000 units
so we're going to be at this line over here
we're gonna produce 9000 gallons of juice
our revenue that we're going to get
is going to be the rectangle of the area
that is high as the price we're getting per unit
times the number of units
so this is gonna be the total revenue we get
if we were to shade this in
I'm not gonna shade this in
because it's going to make my whole diagram messy
and what's our total cost?
well, we have our average total cost right here
this is our average total cost at 48 cents
that's the little green triangle here
so it's 48 cents per unit
times the total number of units
our cost, the area in this rectangle
so if I were to shade this in
this little slightly smaller rectangle
and so our profits are the difference between the two
our total revenue is the area under the rectangle
that has this marginal revenue line as its upper bound
and our cost is the rectangle
that has our average total cost
this line right over here
as its upper bound
so our profits in this circumstance
are going to be the area right over here
the height is the difference between our marginal cost
which is the same as our marginal revenue
and our total cost
so the heigh is going to be
this two cents right over here
we're taking the difference of 50 and 48
so it's gonna be 2 cents
and then, the quantity produced
is going to be 9000 units
so 9000
we're making 2 cents per unit
remember, our average cost
our average total cost is 48 cents per unit
we're selling that 50 cents per unit
so we're making 2 cents per unit
that's not 20
we're making 2 cents per unit
2 cents times 9000 units gives us
that's 18000 cents, or 180 dollars of profit
now what I want you to think about
and we'll answer this in the next video
is does it make sense to sell units at all
and if so, how many units should we sell
if, and here is the question
if the market price is lower
than your average total cost
so does it make sense
and how many units does it make sense to produce
let's say if the market price were 45 cents per unit
does it make sense for us to produce